point number six just be positive it's  all going to work out you know it's just  life is just about positive if you sit  there and you think about positive  thoughts someone's going to knock on  your door with a million dollar sale and  your life's going to change if you think  positive thoughts and sit around after  you apply for 10 jobs someone's going to  call you and they're going to offer you  the job because you're thinking positive  now here's what i'm going to tell you  i'm a big advocate of positive thinkers  there's something unique about working  around somebody that's got positive  vibes positive energy versus a negative  one but i've met a lot of positive broke  people because they don't have any skill  sets they offer you eventually have to  bring value to an organization outside  of just being positive